Okay, we're back
live. I've totally messed up this
Okay. So, what happened
yesterday? Um,
I thought it was going to take me like
15 minutes to set up that machine, which
really it should have taken me 15
minutes to set up that new machine. Uh,
but turns out they shipped it to me with
the wrong operating system, wrong BIOS
settings, and no drivers.
So, uh, yeah, I had to spend like six
hours fixing all
that. Of course, I didn't know that was
the issue.
So, but
Boom. What OS it came with? 22.04, 04
which doesn't have driver support for
590s. It
seems need is
24.04. Bio settings were totally screwed
up. Literally wouldn't even boot with
the drivers once I put them on. And uh
yeah, it's it was a whole mess. Oh, also
another fun thing is I had the machine
bricked for like three hours because I
installed the 570 drivers, which Nvidia
says they're compatible, but then when
you actually install them, you get uh a
like startup time crash error uh before
you even get into the OS, which is
actually you need the 570 open
drivers. So, totally
stupid. Anyways, there's your 5090.
Um, and we can now run stuff with this,
which is
Oh, actually that's better than I
thought. Why is it only
480k here, though? I thought it was
faster on
faster. My screen just went completely
black.
heck.
Um, is the stream still up? Yeah. Why
did my display just totally shut off?
Let me go fiddle with that.
cables. Did it kill my other
terminal? Wait,
what? It killed my other terminal.
Unless I was stupid and closed it
somehow. Oh, put it. Hang
on. It put it on the other screen for
some
reason. There we
go. If this is the uh the speed up, then
I'll be happy with it because that's
like a good 20 30%. That's like actually
decent.
But I don't know if this is the Yes.
So this thing crashed
apparently. This thing got
um got soda but then
Let me I just want to see the steps per
second and such that we were getting out
of
this. This one should be fine for
uh this one or this one.
Okay. So, we have a little bit of
uh we've got some disparities here.
looks
like I think cuz one of the machines
like faster than the other or
something. So these ones get up to 570
590 or
whatever. But then this one here
is only 500k.
Wait. Mu on baseline
3 512. Oh, it's because of the the model
size. Okay. So, this is 512 model dim
runs
500K. So, I probably am not doing that
here. Let's see.
So, we'll seeuh how the 5090 does with
the corrected model
size and we'll get an accurate
benchmark. This one's at 480.
with uh my stuff on my desktop running.
It seems like it's supposed to be at
about Oh, it goes up a little bit, but
that's about
right.
550. It's only like a 10% speed
improvement.
Interestingly, it looks like there's
like somewhat lower copy
overhead. Memory bandwidth maybe has
improved a bit.
Okay. I think the uh they
changed in
PyTorch they changed
Where the hell did they move the Dtypes
to?
there. So, what the heck was wrong?
I just break
something. Welcome YouTube folks.
Plan for today is to do a little bit of
work uh benchmarking this new
and after that we'll queue up some
experiments and then we'll probably do
some
infra do some infradev on puffer.
Oh, maybe this needs to go. Yeah, this
needs to go here.
Uh, this should definitely get
defined unless I have this whole thing
bugged somehow.
Ah, I uh I see.
Yeah, that's a little
awkward.
Uh, I guess we just indent this whole
actually. Well, that's that's going to
screw up the profiling, though.
it. I plan on going through this whole
file and cleaning stuff up a whole bunch
before we get to uh release. Anyways,
So, this doesn't seem any faster at all
than before,
wrong or is it just genuinely not
faster?
It's also possible I'm doing like a dot
float or something in here.
this. Okay, now we actually get some
speed.
700k, but I think B float is slower,
isn't
it? Yeah. So, now we're back to the
original speed.
Oh, wait. This is right
here. This is probably messing it up
here, right? So, let let me make sure
then that I'm doing the uh the whole
thing in float 16 first to really get a
benchmark.
700K. And uh is this whole
thing like is the type correct on all
So maybe it's just that you got to be
careful with your cast.
returns this embedding layer is
returning
um not float 16.
torchautocast linear layers
autocast. So do I have this autocast? I
should, right?
Okay, maybe
um maybe this is supposed to do
something. Let's
see. Okay, so this does work, right?
So it it autocast the output of this
linear
layer and the LSTM
outputs load 16. So this is
correct. The embeddings output float 32
or whatever.
matter. This is the only thing this
buffer that does matter is this float
16.
obnoxious. I'm sure this one still
breaks, right?
But I can't compile with the current
version. That
Okay. So, compile doesn't work since I
did the state change stuff. So, that'll
be part of the uh the refactor. We'll be
then making that thing
work. Um,
uh, for now though, we're able to get
650k without screwing
with. We're able to get like 650k
without screwing with
precision and 700k with screwing with
precision.
The thing is, Captain, I had compile
working and then I had somebody ask me
for a feature to help clean up the uh
the code and it completely [ __ ]
compile. I didn't
realize. This is still pretty
disappointing though anyway you cut it.
only getting like 10% speed improvement.
And like actually the thing that's weird
about this as well is copy overhead is
lower than
before. So it looks like the speed
improvement is
uh maybe it's about the same. So maybe
it is just a flat
10%. More speed increase model size and
depth. I don't know.
Maybe. But like I don't I shouldn't have
a ton of overhead on it
anyways. It might actually be the thing
that I really have to get compile
working and maybe um cudigraphs and
stuff to really get the most out of
it. Maybe that's what we have to
do. Okay.
So, a lot of things on my mind now with
this
Okay, I want to queue up a couple
experiments on neural
MMO. Just look at my current
experiments. Queue up a couple
more. We can do it on this box. It'll be
10% faster.
Whoopdedoo. Actually, I think this one
will be a good one to play with.
Um, maybe I'll leave
What I'll do is I'll leave
automatic mix precision on this
one so we can test if that's actually
stable.
Um, also Abuntu 24 kind of sucks because
you have to do this everywhere. I I have
a potential workaround for it, but I'm
going to have to go do it at the
container level.
I don't know whose dumbass idea it was
to decide that you shouldn't be able to
install Python packages outside of a
virtual environment. Like they should
probably stop writing
software. It's like the dumbest I like I
honestly I honestly don't know what is
wrong with Python that they adopt that
thing. Like how stupid do you have to
be? Oh yeah, our packages should not be
installed outside of a virtual
environment. Like come on, be a real
programming language.
remove this
flag. This one doesn't work
yet. Then we should be good.
Ah, wait. There's one other thing I
forgot.
Okay, good. Now this should give us
pretty clean training
curves and we'll see whether float 16 is
stable.
alone. That is one experiment I wanted
to run.
Second
experiment. Um, are my boxes down or
some [ __ ]
Um, that's
bizarre. Let me go see if there's
like Let me go check on what the hell
just
happened. I see like one of them just
came back up. A couple of them are
coming back up. Let me go check what the
hell's going on, though. That's bizarre.
Well, that's fun to find out. They're
just [ __ ] wired wrong. Um, and
actually, I just saw one of the boxes go
back
off. Seven is back online.
Okay. I'm going to go boot all the
boxes, I guess. I'll be right back.
Jeez. You
know, one of these days once I finish
fixing all the reinforcement learning
software, I'm going to have to go put
everyone in infrastructure out of a job
because nobody can build anything that
[ __ ]
works. Oh my god.
is
crazy. Not even power problems, just the
[ __ ] internet cables somehow being
screwed. And like some of the boxes come
back up and some of them don't. How that
makes any sense, don't ask me.
I can't afford to lose a second day in a
row dealing with [ __ ] info, though.
So, none of my boxes are back. I'm just
going to leave that experiment uh that I
just set up running for
Actually, if I only get one experiment
right now, that's not the experiment I
want to
run. See how far this
Actually, that tells me everything that
I needed to know right there. That
shit's not
stable. Unless it's Is this the good
one? Cap.
I Yeah. Okay. That tells me everything I
need to know actually about that one
already. Um, float 16 doesn't work out
of the box. It's not really expected
to, so I guess no massive surprise
there.
Let's just check our losses real
quick. It just drives me
nuts. All the infrastructure I got to
deal
with. You can't even see it.
Maybe it's not totally messed
up. I mean, now that looks pretty messed
up. At least it's not the same
curve, right?
Definitely not the same
curve. Let's uh let me try a couple
things here.
So
um like this. Now, I
don't I don't know if this does
really
because you're still all on the same
process. Hang on. Let's not be totally
stupid here. If you're all on the same
process, if there's no randomness
involved, they're all going to be the
same anyways.
If they have a seating function, then
it'll get
used. Yeah. I don't know why I was
thinking this was a good idea. This
doesn't make any bloody sense.
does, well, you do want some sort of
randomness actually because when you
multiprocess, right, you don't want them
all to be the same seed across
I actually don't know how the default
seating works in uh in C. You know,
there are a few different ways it could
be implemented.
Okay. So, if you don't seat
it, then it acts as if it's
seated with
it. I'm trying to think what uh what I
would want to seat it with.
I think I know the answer and I'm not
going to like
Okay. So, we're going to leave that
experiment up for now until I figure out
this heating thing.
Um, it probably does make sense to
I think. Does it make
sense? Yeah, because you want this to
work across different processes as
probably probably running on the same
map
everywhere.
Yeah. So if we want these things to be
consistent, we can probably do
um ve level
seating. Let me figure out I need to I'm
I got too many ideas in my head right
now of things that need to be done on
the infra.
So back
level
I also wanted to do
uh
else? I think that's it.
And then there's baselines to there are
baselines to run. Okay.
So I've kind of got two separate
important projects to fiddle with. I
think I want to really make sure that
the end finding stuff is good because
we're actively doing that. So I'll start
with
this. Uh we'll fix
seating arg type checking. I think there
should be a reasonable way to do that.
We will see.
I don't know if we can improve the
logging type stuff at all. We'll have to
look at that. But it's it's not that
this is not important. Uh it it's not
important, but it's urgent, I think,
because uh we're actively porting all
the M's and we'd prefer to only have to
do it
once. Okay, scattered start to my day.
Um but let's just really start one thing
at a time here.
throws me off when like stuff goes wrong
like that with the uh the machines
because, you know, I had a plan with
what I wanted to do today and it kind of
threw everything
off. Oh, and also build caching. Where'd
that file go?
I should even do this one first because
it's annoying as hell.
that's going to try to rebuild freaking
everything
though. These dependencies change but
aren't tracked.
That's going to trigger a lot of
rebuild. I think we will
see. Or it's not going to work at
Yeah, that doesn't trigger
it. You would think it would.
Okay, there's no quick easy fix to that.
It'll work with a clean build, but
there's no quick easy fix to
while. No, the quick hack was
actually decent on this.
work. If the file is there, it copies
it. It doesn't check to see if it does
if there's anything in
it. That's hilarious. Okay. Don't use
gro is
Do you want to pass the seed on reset or
on
both? Maybe on
both cuz you have no idea where they're
going to use RNG, right?
So I think you want it passed on both.
Okay, now all we have to do is unpack
the
AR. Now we have a way of passing seeds.
I'm working on
it. That's what I'm going to do automat.
I'm going to just do it automatically,
semi-automatically. It's slightly
obnoxious because you need
um you still need to know like the Nvid
or
whatever for
multipprocessing. But I did actually
notice like a big difference in the
training curve with the neural MMO. So
now I'm working on it.
Isn't this going to be kind of hard
because we have to take a keyword out,
don't
we? Or maybe not. Maybe we can just call
it twice. You
Yeah, it's the only Yeah, the thing is
that the the uh multipprocessing back
has to give you like one, two, three,
four or whatever and then you can assign
the seats.
So
assuming things each process
There we go. So, this should seed now.
And then all we have to do is
pass this arg
in. And then it'll be like the same
thing on on a knit, I believe.
Yeah. So, it'll be the same thing on a
net
This is kind of errorprone in the sense
that if you forget
to you can forget to seed your end.
Not that bad
though. Not that bad.
I can probably make it like a required
keyword. Oh yeah, it is a required
keyword as
is. I just need a good error message for
it and I'm good.
Yeah, because this can technically call
custom
logic and you now have to do the same
thing in envet, don't
you? So, there's a little bit of
repeated code. Quite a bit of repeated
code even.
And because this has to go
here. Yeah. Now this has to go here.
And now this is literally just uh this
is just seed. You just pass them
directly for this
one. Okay, this is not terrible.
null. Okay, so that
runs. Now I have to get it into
vectorization.
seed. I think it needs to pass it here
as well.
See, I know how to do this in the C.
It's once again the shitty annoying
Python.
I guess with the VEC interface, you
don't expect to pass a big ass list of
seeds, right?
Yeah, because that would require you
messing with the seed in the algorithm
layer. Is that something that you want
to be messing with?
So gross to have to do
that. I mean, I can totally punt on that
for now
because like the thing is that's going
to get
easier. Like eventually we're probably
going to just have a C
vecle or
whatever. Well, no. Shoot because we
need the same code to work for the non C
environments. That's
these, these serial
M its own ascending
seed. I think that's going to be
it. If I can just get each of these its
own ascending seed.
right? So you target this worker
process.
though. Workers. Oh, M's per
worker. So, it does get M's per
worker. Then
I Okay.
I can probably just make this
work because if I do it this way, right?
So, I'm going to have
m. This only needs one
seed and it's going to be equal to
Yeah, because serial containing all the
M's. So C times num M should give you
what you
want. And then it also needs does it
need to know it on reset? It does,
right?
Oh, gross though
because reset comes through
pipe. Yeah, cuz this back end's auto
reset. So, this isn't going to do
anything for you.
So, I think it's just going to
be you take this
out because there's no sense in
providing a seed on reset, is there?
Hang on. You also don't want to seat it
on
reset. That's like
bad. You'd like to keep whatever RNG
state is currently
there.
Okay. So, we take this param out.
Oh, wait. No, it does make sense. I'm
wrong. Hold
on. Because you only ever call it once,
right?
So this should be
seed and then seed is equal to seed.
fine. Okay. So now you actually have
this thing seated
reasonably. You have to do the same
thing.
The same thing here.
seeds. And then how's this look in
multiprock? So from multiprock
right? I think actually both of
these these both should be seated by
default. It's better to have them seated
by
default. Yeah.
So, we'll seat it to 42 by default.
Okay. And now this
does C plus I
Okay. So, now you're going to get like
42, 43, yada
yada. I actually don't like
um 42 as a default seed because that
gets multiplied kind of
weirdly. There's nothing wrong with seed
zero,
right? I don't think there should be.
So, let's like do this on breakout or
something first.
So this one
is back in it failed to unpack seed and
this one's back
reset. So I don't know which one it is.
It looks like it should be a net.
end. You plan to get rid of Syon? What's
the replacement for? Yeah. So let me
show you. This is new. It's in dev.
Um, I'm gonna like put this out to users
first, but I think that people will
dramatically prefer this because it
makes everything a lot easier. So, right
now, every time you implement a new
environment for Puffer Lib, you have to
do
this. So, this is 115 lines worth of
Python that you have to get right. Also,
Syon breaks all debugging from Python to
C. It's very difficult to debug, takes
quite a while to compile, and uh the
compiler error messages kind of suck as
well. So, what the goal is to replace
this with this file right here. So, this
is one file for all the MS. Um, and then
what you'll be able to do with this is
this essentially does what Syon
currently does, but it just does it for
you.
So this is what it looks like now. The
Python looks almost identical to before
except you're using, you know, this
binding vectorzed in it. You just give
it all the tensors like you did before.
You give it all your keyword args and it
will just make vectorized M's for
you. So this is the original Syon. It
looks almost the same except it has the
Syon
binding. But now you don't have to write
a Syon binding. All you do have to write
is this tiny little binding file where
you just specify all the args and then
you unpack
them. So you know this 30
lines instead of the original
120. So much much shorter
bindings. Um this also lets me improve
logging a little bit. Logging gets
easier as well. We handle logging quite
nicely now too. So hopefully this should
generally be better for people and you
can debug through it. So if anything
goes wrong in your C now you can just
run Python through GDB and you will get
a break point right wherever something
breaks in your C.
folks. What I'm doing currently with
this is I'm trying is this piine? No,
this is this is the cool thing. No
external dependencies. It's just the
Python C API. That's it.
And um what I'm trying to do right now
is also make it support nice seating so
that you never have stuff screwed up
because of bad seating and make it like
really really obvious how to do that and
really hard to screw up. That's what I'm
doing at the moment. And then I've got
the whole agenda. Um I want to make it
harder to screw up argument passing to
these M's. Give you really nice error
messages for if you screw up your
arguments. And then maybe some
improvements to logging. And that's all
that I need to do with end of finding to
make this like really solid. And after
that, we'll move on to training side
improvements. Well, probably I'm going
to get through this and then uh go take
a break, get some exercise, and do the
rest in the evening. We'll
see. So, this gives you seed
zero. Uh but somehow it does not
like does not like this unpacking
message.
I wonder if um if I actually shot myself
in the
foot. Yeah, I probably shot myself in
the foot here. Huh? Because this
probably gives you a good error message
that I
here function takes at most one
argument 21 given the
takes when will the new binding version
be shipped? Um, we currently have
experimental stuff on Pong Breakout and
Neural MMO 3 in the dev branch. And then
as with everything else in Puffer Lib,
it only goes to main when we ship a new
major
version. We have a pretty long dev cycle
for uh for major versions. I usually
only ship, you know, two or three majors
a year because the next one will
probably be like 2.5 or
something, you know.
What do you
want? Oh, I see the
So this is the behavior that I expected
but this is not what I'm
Oh, is it because of args? Yeah, it's
because of this args, isn't it?
Okay, so this is done
here
seed. Oh, maybe it's that I need to do
this.
Is this no longer where it's crashing?
Come
this. I think Grock is just [ __ ]
wrong with how this
works. The problem is the docs for this
in Python also kind of suck. was the
only reason I was using it.
Empty names denote positional only
parameters.
Do I have to like extract a single
keyword?
I mean, I could pretty easily just make
this
thing. Hang on. I I know what I can do
for now at least if I don't want to
fight this cuz this is also going to
make it more annoying for user. I
think though it does give them access to
the seed if they need
it. I don't know if they need access to
the seed
themselves. And I think we can do it
this way for now.
See how we do
this? So, I had to do this before.
I think we do
this. So this is going to be
seed get ar
here. Yeah. So, we can just do
this and then all we have to do is
modify this to
take is it six back six arcs?
zero. Oh, in that case you can kind of
just unpack
um yeah, you don't need all these
arcs. So we can simplify it a little
bit.
Uh yes, it is at
one. Okay, it takes two arguments then
because uh you're
unpacking. Yes, it takes two arguments.
So this is now arc
this. You are making the seed required
by doing
this. I think that's okay for
now. Think that's okay for now.
until I figure out the API a little
better.
double get item
five. That's
fine. Get rid of this.
runs. Okay, back in. It
requires six arguments.
stuck? Looks like we're spinning our
wheels and nothing's
happening. That's not good. I don't
think I introduced anything that could
cause a loop.
There was an error
there. Unrecognized
arguments binding back reset.
Yeah, this just needs meth bars, not
meth
keywords. And
not. So, this just needs R. Doesn't need
keywords.
unrecognized. Oh, because this is
partle.
We get unrecognized
arguments. That seems like this just
didn't get
recompiled. Oh, no. We're still getting
just
unrecognized. Must be here. Oh, same
problem. Nope.
Same exact
this. I got to do a couple quick things.
I'll be back in a
few. And uh then soon as I'm back, we
will finish this. Plan will be to get
seating working, get a couple other
things working.
Um probably this and then the checks was
what we'll get done this morning. Be
back soon.
seed. Okay, so this is beck seed zero,
vex seed one. This is correct. So it's
good going into
this and
then reset
takes
integer. It's correctly passed
here.
See? Uh, okay. So, this doesn't even get
used
because Yeah. So, this doesn't even seem
to get used because I guess we're not
going through serial in this case, which
I guess we like we normally shouldn't be
going through serial in most of our M's
anyways. So, it's getting screwed up
here. Oh, I see. I see it. the reset
seed. Yeah. So, this doesn't need to be
uh this doesn't need to be make
seed. This just needs to be seed plus I,
right?
or hang on. Yeah. C plus
I. And then internally it's up
to the worker to use this
Okay, so we get past
that argument must be an integer
Um, well, yeah, that's not going to
freaking work,
right? Is this how I had it
before? Think you just I long check the
R.
stop.
Wait, how the hell does this make any
sense?
end. Don't we have an unpack function
for
Yep. That's perfect.
Now all we got to do, so this gives you
seed one and seed two it looks like.
get? Zero and then 01. So, this is just
the um the default end. That that one
doesn't matter at
all. We get seed zero and seed one. So,
why did we get seed one and seed two on
the uh the other ones? I see that
Mark
seed. That's fine.
fine. Are boxes down because you're
swapping to 5090s? No, boxes are down
because the internet is ass. And I don't
know if something's wrong with the cable
or whatever. I've got to go deal with
it. But I can't have two days in a row
of just dealing with infrastructure
horseshit. So I got to go figure that
out after I at least make a little bit
of progress
here. Let's see the 5090
run. Like it's literally impossible for
me to broken anything with the 5090.
It's like in a different room on a
different
right. So, this is going to do whatever
it's going to
do. I think some of the boxes are back
as well. It's It's bizarro, but I think
that they have like dial up internet
speed right now for some dumb reason.
Okay. Well, this is this is correct so
far.
Um, this now should give you unique
seeds. I'm going to test it for neural
MMO.
trans. Now here you actually have to do
the seed manually.
um times numbum m plus i
plus
This just is a compile error. Doesn't
seem to be
compiled. And okay, builds.
Can we
train? Yes. Yes, we can train. No
errors, same training speed. And I guess
we will see whether there are any uh any
differences.
I'd like to remove this stupid flashing
problem at some
point. I'll put that on the to-do
list. I think I know how to do it now.
I'm looking at it. I'm fine. Um, that
runs. That's good.
I want to make sure that the seeds
though are are
good. I want to definitely make sure
that the seeds are
have unique
seeds.
Seed.
Okay. So, this is the the um driver M.
This one doesn't
matter. One, two, three, zero.
One, two, three, four, five, six,
seven. Oh, this is the whole driver
because it's going to make Yeah. And
then it goes 0 1 2 3 and four, five,
six, seven.
Perfect. So, we have unique seeds for
each environment.
Now, that should be consistent as well.
that might actually substantially change
the training based on some uh
preliminary results. So, we will have to
run
this. But, this is going to be a good
change
overall. Let's just uh let's do breakout
real quick just so we have like a little
bit more
confidence in this result.
See, I don't know why this has so many
bloody arguments. It's kind of
ridiculous.
rewards.
See, and because this is Beckinet,
that's all we have to do with it.
Rebuild
breakout. Whatever the hell that did
here
is deal. Wrong
one. And
actually print seed here as
Then it's also we changed it to ve in
it instead of it
back. Yep. So 0 and one plus the default
zero 1.6 million steps per second. We'll
make sure that this still trains nicely.
Good. Okay. So, that is
seating. I'm going to say that's seating
complete.
solves. I'm actually tempted to
normalize the score for all the M's. 0
to
one. We'll think about that later
though. Okay, so this now runs.
Um, I think it's going to be worth just
doing this on neural MMO because I don't
know what's going to happen.
So I think what we do is we take a look
at the current neural MMO
experiment. We see whether that result
is
reasonable and then we launch this one
on. Yeah, cuz this is running with weird
RNG.
Let's just take a quick look at the
losses to see if there's anything
weird. Yeah. Okay. There is definitely
something weird here. This clip frack is
really
low. Entropy is really weird. Okay. So,
yeah, the float 16 is definitely
screwing with training somehow.
It does seem to be learning, but there's
definitely weirdness going
on. I mean, yeah, we're not intending to
train in float 16 anyways. The really
the goal would be to get BF16 to be
fast, then train in
BF-16. Um, here, let's commit all this
up and then go run this on the 1590.
If you are looking at these new cards
for RL, I will say that the results so
far have been pretty disappointing. It's
only like 10 15% faster in the tests
I've run thus
Okay. So now we have nice
clean version to run this
experiment. Yeah, honestly the cards are
really disappointing thus far. They do
have 32 gigs of memory on them, but like
I don't know what we do with that,
right? Like what are we even using right
now? Yeah, we're literally using 4 gigs
of RAM with like the biggest model that
we run.
So, what's the
point? Uh, I will say that we did screw
up. So, this should be
increased. Hang on. Let me just increase
the model size. So, it actually will use
a little bit more RAM than I than 4
gigs. Maybe quadruple. Maybe use a
No, cuz uh we did get better results
with
fivefold premp compute more things for
Tokyo Puff. Not really though, cuz it's
in uh it's in GPU. It's more GPU memory,
right? Tokyo Puff might be a really RAM
heavy
M. But the thing is, I intentionally
spec our machines with high RAM
specifically so we can do stuff like
Tokyo Puff anyways. Like
look, these things
have well, okay, it's not on top or
whatever, but these things have 128 gigs
of RAM on
them. Should be plenty for a one card
run, right? You'd hope. I don't know,
maybe giant giant map could be
challenging, but
this. We get up to 700K with uh
blo. I just pulled the fix that got rid
of that.
uses and then
uh we'll keep thinking about the other
infra
stuff. Environment requires five
arguments. Didn't recompile.
Okay. So this is now this is a 3.1
million parameter
model. Um trains at
[Music]
560k steps per second. 550 560k.
You can see that we don't really have
any wasted time in MISK. Very little in
copy for a large amount of data at
least. So what's this take
It's actually kind of weird that you can
increase the model size that much and um
still not have it take up any
memory. I guess it's just the obs buffer
is taking up everything, right? And then
the actual batch of data that you have
on GPU is not really doing
much. And this is decent util as well,
right?
We can probably make the thing run like
20% faster if you're looking at just
util. Is there a way in the end we can
separate various tasks for
GPU like complex physics sims to utilize
GPU more? Nope. Yeah, at that point
Spence, you got to do the whole end GPU
because you don't want to be doing back
and forth device transfer in the end.
I actually do have a plan though for um
making it very easy to do uh GPU
accelerated puffer amps. So if that
becomes a problem in GPU drive, I will
let's say I will uh work on making those
additions faster. But there is actually
a plan for GPU enabled um puffer
environments without having to do like
terrible terrible jacks or pietorrch
array [ __ ] In fact, I think it'll
work with mostly the exact same code you
have now. So, there's plan for that.
It's got a really fun logo attached to
it, too. But, uh, more about that when I
actually get a spare few days to
dev. And I got to fire uh I got to if it
works, I'll have to find an artist for
the logo as well.
collection. Actually, I know exactly the
artist I would use.
Um, yeah, I can do I had two artists
work on this puffer, so I can just go
get the same artist to do uh a new
model. The the one who like really
cleaned it up
nicely. He did a great job with the
animations on this guy.
Okay, next thing.
Um, the only thing we have left to do on
the initial version of the end binding
is just seeing if we can improve a
little bit of the
usability because right now
This binding is really easy to mess
up. If you mess up any of the D types
here, it just corrupts all the
data. Would puff would GPU puff be
faster for certain types of MS? Yeah,
for certain types of MS, of course.
The only thing in GPU drive I can think
about by the way where like you might
want to do it kind of the collision
checks but you kind of make it harder to
use better algorithms if you do that. So
I think like the only thing I can think
about is if you were going to do like
lidar, right? If you were going to do
lidar then you probably want GPU
Excel. But the thing is then you have to
make the whole M GPU Excel which is not
going to be that hard codewise. But I
don't know if it's going to be
slow. A lot of the times people try to
write stuff on the GPU to make it fast
and they just end up making it slow
because GPUs are not just dropping
replacements for CPUs. They don't work
that
way. Would be cool if they
did. We just like make basically a
thousand core
CPU. That'd be
nice. Does it help for robotics? Yeah,
of course it helps for robotics, right?
if you wanted to actually So, if I
wanted to go deep into robotics and
really make a sim platform for that,
right? I mean, you're kind of doing what
Isaac uh Isaac Sim or whatever does at
that point, but like let's say that I
thought that I could do a better job
than Isaac Sim, then yeah, I would
probably go off of Nvidia Physics and
like write my own custom thing with
PhysX and CUDA.
But that's like a that's a big ordeal.
That's like a big ordeal.
So you can manually type check which is
annoying.
[Music]
ish. Okay. So, it's basically it's
between
through pi float check punch. I wonder
if I could just write some like unpack
args function that just does all the
dype checks, right? I mean, you're just
going to want like floats and
ins. So I can just do those checks for
you.
It's definitely worth
trying. And then you wouldn't need to
deal with these types either. So you
wouldn't have to provide this
This is pretty much the last thing I
think that I could do that would be like
a legitimately a legitimate improvement.
After that, anything more starts to get
like overbuilding it.
Unpack. Holy hell. What? Super Maven,
chill
out. Have you seen any research on
maximum steps?
PPO can solve an M with a only a reward
at the end of an episode for Gigaspar's
problems.
Um, so there is something I've been
thinking about like where there's a
legitimate point to improve PO on that
specifically, but in general it's
not you need it like it it's not so much
just how many steps it's delayed, right?
Like that's not the only thing that
matters. The thing that matters is the
path that you take to get it. So, like
if I run a random
policy, right? If I run a random policy
on the M, uh, how long does it take me
to get the
reward? If you never get the reward,
then you're not going to be able to
learn anything
credit assignment becomes the issue then
right like huge sequence but did get
yeah so PO is not going to work if you
only get the reward once in theory right
there are environments for which you
should be able to learn only by getting
the reward once um you know if you have
a fully deterministic end where it's all
you need to do is repeat the same
sequence of actions then you probably
should be able to get back to that
reward uh these are kind of like
pathologies, right? These are like weird
edge cases where current algorithms
fail. Um, I actually been thinking about
that one because this is where it starts
to make sense to consider off policy
stuff because if you get that trajectory
into an experience buffer and then you
just keep training on it because there's
nothing else to train on, you will solve
the problem because you'll just overfit
the solve trajectory. Uh, however, off
policy in general is a total mess. So
while the idea of off policy of having
like this buffer is a good one, the
actual implementation and practice of
these things kind of suck. Like PO is a
really simple algorithm and then if you
look at all the off policy ones that try
to match POFF, they're a mess.
So yeah, it's definitely a valid
research direction and something we'd
like to look at, but uh it would have to
be done in a way that doesn't produce
the amount of mess that is currently in
off policy.
What did this just
autofill? Hi, Unicode from string. God,
that is totally
awful. I have no idea what the heck it
just tried to fill in there.
Thanks for chat. Was reading alpha chip
paper and thought it was wild they only
had one joint reward
given at the end of episode. I haven't
actually looked at the chip design
stuff.
Um they also this is very large scale as
well, right?
though. Actually, I don't know. Maybe
their sim is
slow. You can kind of force
reinforcement learning to work on a ton
of problems. It's really just a matter
of like, does it work immediately? Does
it work after playing with it for a
couple hours? Do do you need a team of
20 in two years?
I don't know if there's there isn't a
length built in,
is fix. So, this actually does work
because
Yeah, this is the size of the char star.
So, we're good. So, this has to
be
static. You just have to know how to
model the problem for RL, then build
fast. Pretty
much. Pretty much.
it. Is there a way to like get a
single a single
arg? I don't want to have to deal with
this format shenanigans.
arcs picked
get item
string. Is this a real function? Get
item
Okay. So now you got to go
check the different types
So this is the idea right is that all
supported key uh keyword types we get
the type it is in
still this is still sketchy though isn't
Yeah, this is still
sketchy because if you pass an
inch to a float, it'll still break,
won't
Oh, wait. No. Does it not? Does it
break? No, it doesn't break. I'm wrong.
Hang on. I think I have it because now
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. We're good. We are
good. Okay. I was being stupid. So this
is this is actually correct. And the
reason is that before um it was trying
to like do some weird thing where it was
casting the Python object into the wrong
D type or whatever, but now it's going
to match the type of
the Yeah, it's going to match the
type that you bring into it. It still
needs to get cast
though. Yeah. Okay. Okay, it still needs
to get cast. So, this cast doesn't work.
closer. Now, you don't need a [ __ ]
metadata type system. Screw that.
this? Handles both floats and
ins. This doesn't work though, right?
If the user writes this line
themsself, the casting will be
So, all I really need to do is give them
a
um an unpack
function that returns a
float. Is there anything else you really
need to pass to
MS through the C
API? It's always going to be a float or
an in, right?
I think you can technically screw this
up, right? Cuz the float precision won't
work. Yes, you can. Yes.
Right. I mean, obviously. I don't even
know why I
article. This is Dreamer V3. This isn't
even anything new, right?
This is just they got their scammed like
their [ __ ] paper into
nature. Yeah.
Look, whole page of uh totally wrong
stuff. That's fine. They can get
[ __ ] published all they
want. I thought you were going to tell
me that there's a Dreamer V4 that's even
more [ __ ] and now we have to run
another 10 hours worth of exper uh
10,000 GPU hours worth of experiments.
Then I'd be mad.
Now we're fixing stuff over here, man.
We're fixing
stuff. First 5090 is in as
well. We're running a neural MMO on it
right
now. Now we're going to hear even more
about it. Yeah. But you know what
happens? Every time like a client or you
know, whoever asks me about it, I say
yes, we evaluated it. We did 10,000 GPU
hours worth of experiments on all the
tricks they claimed. None of them
worked. We have the results published at
Right. No, no, no. I like the world
model stuff probably works, but it's
just god-awful science to the point that
it's like borderline scientific fraud.
Especially when you consider that the
author should have known better, right?
This is like if this were some random
undergrad or even some random grad
student at some random lab, right? I'd
just say like, "Ah, okay, whatever. They
they made some mistakes, whatever." But
no, like these people should know
better,
delayed. Are you sure?
I I didn't change anything. It shouldn't
be. Twitch is usually the fast
reream. I don't have it set to de I
don't have a delay set or anything
weird.
Cool. Might be
me. That's like 30 seconds, not 2
minutes. Twitch just gave me two minute
delay for no
reason. Yeah, there you go.
Sometimes it like scrolls back in the
live broadcast or
Okay. Oh, I got a new thing. I don't
know if you saw this, Ryan. I've been uh
replacing Syon. We found a really nice
way to replace Syon, and I'm just kind
of polishing it up right now.
So, we're going to have one 500 some odd
line file instead of like 3,000 lines
worth of Syon
bindings. Dreamer does actually work,
but their science sucks. Well, yeah, but
the thing is their science sucks so bad
that it's like it's almost not a
youthful result
anymore, you know?
They also use these like stupid ass slow
environments where it's really hard to
even get a good baseline for comparison
because you can't even ask like okay you
know how like can you solve this
environment easily with more samples you
can't even ask like does the stupid
baseline just solve this easily right is
it just a sample thing like even for
stuff where you want to do sample
efficiency research like you'd want it
on fast end
working algorithms always I mean you
read the code for that
thing I don't think it's a working
okay we will do more algo side stuff
going
forward I want to
fix the plan at the moment is fix
bindings take another path with the
trainer. See if we can really get some
train purf uh going on that. And then we
go back to more
algorithms. So it's infra. So I just did
an algorithm block and then it's going
to be infra. And then it's going to be
PF and then it's going to be back to
algorithms. Also, I'm visiting the um
the new facility. Um it's not done yet.
And I'm visiting the new facility over
the weekend. Uh so I'll get to see that
which will be
cool. Yeah. But this thing is awesome.
Like here and I think it's going to get
even easier than
this.
But this is your binding for neural MMO.
Now this is the entire binding you have
to write for neural MMO. The gym and
data center. Yeah.
visiting that. It's not quite done yet.
It'll be done in a few weeks, but
visiting
it. Probably visiting it. We'll
see. So, yeah, this is all you have to
write for neural
MMO. What the [ __ ] is that
string? Yeah. So, this is what I'm
trying to remove right now. This this
dtype string sucks. So, I'm trying to
figure out how to remove this right now.
And I think I'm going to have it just so
you just write one line per param
instead of having this [ __ ] because
this can actually screw you because this
can do bad
tasks. Like this can actually cause you
to do wrong
Wrong
tasks of wrong casts. WC wrong
casts. This is what we had for neural
like this replaces 270 lines of Python
binding though. That one little
thing. Wrong. In what way? You try to
write uh the bits of a float to an int
and then you break the values. It's
really gross. So, we're trying to fix
that right
now. What if I just give you an unpack
int and an unpack float function?
That just does it, doesn't
it? I haven't gotten on the sea train
yet. You're missing out. You're really
missing out, buddy.
It's actually so the C is really chill
and it gets even better uh as time goes
on because more and more people are just
jumping on the like I don't know
anything. I just ask LLM's everything
train. So it's even more funny to see
like how hilariously better you can make
stuff just by knowing a little bit of
low-level dev because like people are
now just writing [ __ ] that's like you
know a thousand times too slow, 10,000
times too slow. I've seen 20,000 times
too slow at this All right.
might take a stab at writing syllabus in
written
C. Oh, don't try to directly translate
it with an LLM. You will be
sad. You'll be very
sad. But uh we are getting nice puffer
and vin. So, you know, you'll be able to
hop with hop on some of this. In fact,
we're probably going to do
multipprocessing backends at some point
relatively soonish with this as well,
just because I'm sick of dealing with
the Python. I think it'll literally be
shorter and simpler in uh in C than in
Python. Isn't that
funny? Near MMO 3 looks really cool. Oh
yeah. And we have it now training. It's
at on the 5090. We're up to 650,000
steps per second training. Uh, it goes
up to 700,000 if I do it in float 16. I
haven't gotten that stable yet. I
haven't gotten compiled on that yet. So,
I think we're going to get up to like
eight or 900,000 steps per second
training on neural MMO 3. That's with a
3 million parameter network as
well. Buffer very fast. Buffer very
fast.
It's a totally different
game. Lost the task system
though.
Yeah. I mean, that doesn't mean it's
gone forever. It's just for this version
of it. It's not. This is not the final
version of
Neuralarmmo. The coolest open source
task. Yeah, I agree.
But it's okay, right? Here, like the
thing is like make the [ __ ] RL work,
right? Let's solve neural MMO 3 and then
we'll like figure out how to make a good
task system for neural MMO
4. Yeah, the baseline the old baseline's
a pain. So, the new it was a tenth uh it
we were only at like level two and a
half or whatever before. I think the
best baseline got two and a half level
average.
So the new one we're up to this one is
at 4.5 in like 60 billion
steps is the new best. So if I run this
for 100 bill again this will be like
five. So essentially five out of 20 max
levels 20.
That curve keeps going up like perfect
log linear over a 100red billion steps
too which is pretty
cool curriculum learning you know you
might it's kind of tricky though if
you're not doing it over task
space we're only training on eight total
maps the maps are really
big
so You could potentially like randomize
and have like an easy, medium, and hard
map or something in
there like you can do that. And
actually, neural MMO 3 is set up so that
you can do that very very easily.
Um, oh here, let me show you the new
endbinding stuff as well. You can write
you get to write your envy now. It's
pretty nice.
So this is how you do your envy. All
that was just arch check. Look at this.
You just call envenit and you just make
whatever end you want with whatever
arguments you want and then you just
call
vectorize. That's
it. And even after you vectorize, you
can still call step and reset on
individual M's if you want.
This is the new
infra. So when you're initializing
neural MMO
3, you can initialize different
instances with like whatever args you
want and then you can call vectorize and
then you can do the step over all the
different M's in pure
C which is pretty nice.
So, this actually is built to make it
really easy to do curriculum learning
type stuff. Can you change the tasks?
There are no tasks. Remember, there are
no tasks. Um, you can reset individual
ends. You can probably technically do a
few other things with them as
well, but there's no task system in this
yet, right? This is just
uh you can change the math though
like two reward functions. Oh yeah. No,
you can do that. That type of stuff
isn't that hard to
make. Yeah, that's not that's not hard
to
do. I mean ultimately like this binding
is specific to neural MMO as well. So
you can just write arbitrary C in there.
you change that and
reset. Uh you could probably get it to
add an argan to reset or something if
you
wanted. I don't know. I would probably
just say add a different function would
be easier, right? Just like expose and
like have like a binding set state or
whatever and then just call
that. But still this is already like way
easier because at least here the thing
that you can do with this that you could
not do before you can step and reset
individual M's with this because this M
byD here if you just store this as a
list right like you can step individual
ones of these M's and reset individual
M's but you also don't lose the
vectorzed functionality so it's pretty
nice this whole thing. It's like 500
lines of Python API C
shenanigans. What you're looking at as
well, this is not considered like easy
to read like clean C. The M's are easy
to read clean C. This is garbage Python
API stuff. So most of the code in Puffer
is way better than this, but like the
Python API is what it is. So you have
all of these like pi object, pi dict, pi
false. So there's still more to be done
here, but I'm very happy to cut down the
amount of total binding code from like 2
to 3,000 lines down to 500 because it's
so much easier to do stuff now.
well tested. It's not really that it's
an like a total ugly mess. It's just it
has to use the Python API which is kind
of verbose, right? So there's like a
bunch of annoying checks. You always
have to check every operation because
like anytime you're doing something on a
Python object like you don't know what
the type of the Python object is, you
have to check it otherwise you are sad.
No one doing research should need to
read this. Well, I mean folks in Puffer
will, right? Because we're closer to the
infra. The goal, my goal here is no
longer just to provide like a convenient
highle interface for researchers, right?
My goal is to solve RL
Oh, that's actually really shitty. Hang
on. You don't have access to this
function yet, do you?
Crap. I can just put it in a separate
header file.
Oh, I can just prototype here. I can
just prototype it. It's fine. I just I
just exposed the
either, man. I don't want you to have to
include two files.
writing thesis and now defense
presentation and job apps. Yeah, it's
rough. It's no
fun. Defending Monday almost out. Hey,
congrats,
Congrats. I forget. I don't know if I'm
flying on on um Sunday, Monday, or
Tuesday, but if I'm not fly in the air
and you send me a link, I will gladly be
there. And I promise not to ask you any
[ __ ]
doctor. No pressure. Hey, if I'm not
flying, I'll be there.
worth. Good luck. Thank you. Okay, back
to infra. So, here's the HP, right? This
file gets included second. So, you can't
use anything from this file right now.
available. What if we what if we just
prototype it for now just to see if it's
even
useful? Like
this? Now we have access to this stupid
thing.
Um, and
then let's comment this
int. So this is float float
float and end in int.
float. Yeah. And everything else is
fine. Now, the only thing I can think
right is if you use the int function on
a float, you're going to round
it. But I this is way better than having
to match a freaking string.
This ends up not really being any longer
either because you don't have to declare
this annoying thing anymore or do all of
this. Okay.
class. Okay, this doesn't have to be
static. I don't know why I'm starting to
use stupid keywords that I don't need.
like where the hell else does it think
this is uh
C.
Oh,
for Oh, I just pasted this here and I
forgot about it.
Okay,
uh pi error set
string. You actually do need to do
format string. C doesn't have any like
nice format string, right?
This is a buffer overflow right there
I'm making. Let's not add a buffer
overflow in the buffer for no freaking
reason.
Right. Invalid types. The keyword reward
market.
reward market as
float.
Okay. Um why did it fail?
now. So, what do we think about
uh about this? So definitely this quarks
unpack thing doesn't
work because you lose the type of the
message. It should be an easy to
understand error message. It's a little
fiddly on what type you have to provide
at the moment. Technically, uh, what I
could do is I could make
it I could probably make it like try to
cast. So try to if you unpack it as an
int and it's a float, right? It'll try
to unpack it and it'll check if the
values are the same. I could do
that. Yeah, but this is totally fine
right now.
Oh, I didn't realize that uh I didn't
have the model size correct on my
machine. So, actually, it looks like the
uh
the 5090 is a little better than I'd
originally thought.
Okay, that's not
terrible. I like this.
Now, the only thing we got to figure out
is this [ __ ] right here,
right? Because we need these functions.
Um, but the way this is set up, you have
to have endbinding defined after you're
in it.
on. We just
define Mayanet up here, right?
If we're going to call all of these
binding as
better. And now, hang on. You no longer
need to include
python.h. And you can include it in the
correct spot where like a sane person
would.
Why did we suddenly get a whole bunch of
bears?
That just somehow got unincluded, but
actually it works perfectly
fine. Do we use end module name anywhere
anymore?
uh all the marbles. I
guess C step
reset. We no longer need these.
That's pretty damn
good. What do you think? Easy enough to
bind your
Why do I have ads in my
Discord? They literally have a didn't
ask
button. All right, you're forgiven.
Well, I'm happy with
this. This is kind of the best possible
outcome. You
know, there's basically nothing you can
do to make this simpler, right?
Can I make it a
void? A void
Voidar
can't inherently convey type
information. Yeah, that's Yeah, that's
true. Because it needs to actually know
how to do the cast.
value.
Return. Now, I don't want a value like
that. That's bizaro.
I think this is worse than just having
separate functions though. I think it's
just
dumb. Yeah, it would still have to be a
void star.
because yeah, the only thing you'd be
able to do is cast to an int and then
you
risk rounding being screwy,
right? You don't want to store it as a
float.
There's no other type I can store it as,
right?
Oh,
wait. I didn't realize
this. I didn't realize that double can
actually store all 32-bit ins. So,
that's
Oh, it is totally true, right? Because
of the number of bits exponent mintisa,
right? So bits.
Yeah, because it
has
53. Okay, so I'm stupid. It should just
be a double and we're
done.
Okay, this is why knowing low-level
stuff is important, right? Because
literally the the error that I made here
is I assume that you would lose
precision on the double way before uh
max int. But you
don't. So I can literally just Now this
is beautiful, right?
Oh, this is going to be so
nice. Look at this.
Oh, I think it'll just
work as
double and
now. And you don't even need to
cast. You don't even need to cast
anymore because it'll auto cast from
double. So this is basically
perfect. So like why something like this
isn't built in, I have no idea.
So this is actually
perfect and this handles I'll no longer
need to do the thing where
um I like had to define the floats as
floats and the instance inside. This
will just work. This will just freaking
work. That's the unused function. We're
going to delete that in a second
anyways.
Even better. I actually made it
better. I didn't think that was going to
work before. I didn't think I'd be able
to do that. So now this
is the only time this is unsafe is uh if
you go outside of the range of max int,
which at that point, screw
you. We're good.
We're
absolutely good
here. Oh, and I can actually wait. PI
long
check pie long as long. Oh, I can even
do
Perfect. So now we don't have any any
possible
errors. Now this is a perfectly safe
unpack function.
Perfect. I'm very very proud of that.
You know, it's like these very small
things where it's you have to actually
spend a few hours to get these really
really right. But now look at this. I
mean, look at the result of
this. This is how easy it is to bind
environments. Now, this is how easy it
is. Let's do this now for uh for Pong
and for Breakout and um yeah, we'll go
from there.
Look at this. This is what we had for
Paul.
Disgusting by comparison.
Width, height, paddle width, paddle
height, ball width, ball height, speed,
initial
speeds, X,
Perfect. Was there a
function. There is an init function on
Pong,
right? So, we just do that.
This is
like I'm very very proud of
this comparison between pointer and
integer. That is bad.
But uh yeah this that is very bad. So we
will fix
Honestly, in my mind, this makes puffer
lib so much
better. This is just like effortless C
to Python for all your
M's, right?
There's no in it on this. Yes, there is
no on
this
height paddle with paddle height ball
with width ball height brick width kite
rows columns and continuous That's
perfect.
And you'll actually even if you screw
up, you'll still get pretty much
anything that you could conceivably
screw up
here. You will get a a reasonable error
message. Good at the very least. And
this is bet, so we don't worry about
that.
per this
is huge
success. Huge success.
I'm feeling pretty good. I want to keep
going on stuff. I think we take on
um Let's see. So, ah, wait. We didn't do
we didn't think about struck blogging at
all. To be fair, that one I don't know
if we have any way
around. Okay, I'll think what I'll do
here is I'll think about this for a few
minutes. Then I'll take a few minute
break and then I'll come back and we'll
do um infra other infra. I don't know
about this logging stuff
though
like this is how simple we have logging
right now. You just define your log keys
and you define an enum with your values
and uh everything else is handled for
you.
Oh, you know what? There is a way to do
it,
Okay, I think I know how we're going to
do this. It's actually we're going to
write something that looks very very
similar to what we just
wrote because basically all this does
it's the same problem that I just solved
right all we basically need is we need a
way to map um it's it's the inverse of
the problem though right so we just need
a way to grab an element from a a crruct
and then assign the result of that uh
to a Python dict. So all we'll do is
we'll just make like a my logger or
whatever and then you won't have to do
this in this file. Yeah. Okay, that'll
be perfect. That will be actually
perfect. But that is going to take me a
little bit of work. And I need to I've
been deving for a few hours. I need to
go grab a drink. I need to walk around
for a couple minutes and then we'll be
back. The binding file will get slightly
longer. Um, but there's going to be a
trade-off, right? And the trade-off will
be that the logging becomes exactly what
you want it to be. So essentially, you
will have the binding file still as easy
as possible, no added complexity, just
you know, you write out this stuff
there, zero added complexity to your
actual end implementation, which is
crucial. Uh, and no like perf loss
either. So I'll be right back and then
we will do that. Give me a few
Okay, here's the
plan. I got a little over two
hours to totally fix the
logging and have this clean end binding
stuff set and done and done.
Then I can let Bet handle updating the
rest of the MS with it. This should make
it very, very easy
though. Got a little bit of food real
quick. Now I am good for
uh good to get this done.
Okay. So, first
things
um let's go find the old login because
we need that
episode length, episode
return, score, and it
has end. We can just make end float
because why
not? Delete. Delete. Delete.
log. It's cleaner, right? So, we don't
have to even do this weird thing that I
was planning on adding. I don't know why
I thought that was a good idea. I was
being stupid, I guess, because I didn't
see the way to do it with uh this new
thing. Uh, and that should actually be
it for this end.
So, we add the log
strct and then everything else is just
gone. Right now, what we need to do
log.
Okay, so this is going to get called
somewhere. Let me just see how I do the
aggregation right
Um, okay. There is a slight issue here,
right? Iterating over the
keys. [ __ ] Did I not think this
through?
I forgot there's a second part to this,
right? So for part
one, you have to uh average all the
dictionaries or average all the
strs and then part
two is that you have to add them to a
dictionary.
We don't want to go through the pi dict
API and then average. That'll be
slower. Yeah. So having those keys
defined before, what did that do for me?
it. I do know a really stupid way to do
it.
Well, we don't have to do it
here.
Nice. But we do have to
do we do have to do it here.
There's no other way to iterate through
the keys of a str
I know how to do this a little more
safely.
Okay. And now this is where you actually
need your custom logic, right?
There's no way around custom logic here
because you need to know the
keys. But you actually don't need to do
this gross thing anymore.
And then you do have to go over
the the uh the keys. You have to do this
[ __ ] one more
time in order to do the
division. Uh you don't need to do this
part though. You only need this
user
picked and then all you need to do is
this function, right?
idict under the
log, right? And then you just
do Okay, that is actually kind of
annoying that you need to do this task.
So what we'll do
Yeah. So this is
it. So you have some like assigned to
dict
function. I actually want it the other
way.
assignment. I can do this
assignment. This is no longer
needed. There's this
average. This is no longer needed.
Is there anything we can
do about this aggregate
differently? You know, I think you just
need a required key, right?
It doesn't have to be in any specific
order, but I think you do need to have a
required key in their end
somewhere. Technically, you can do it
right here, though.
No, because you need the total
n. Yeah. So, you do need to do it the
way I had it. Okay. This is still nice
and
clean. This is still nice and clean.
works and then we will uh we'll consider
whether this is the best it could
possibly
be. Request for
member N.
does have an
N implicit
pi dict
object. Is pi dict object a
thing? Let me go look how I have this on
dev right now.
because something happened with the
types. I like I must have messed
something
up. Okay. So, where do you do this
logging right now?
Here. Pi dict
new. Yeah. Okay. So, this I don't know
what this pi dict object thing is. I
don't know if this even exists, but uh
whatever it is, you don't need
it. So, this is just a pi object star.
object. Oh, I know what it is. Support
declaration's
wrong. My
dict. This one's easy. This is just this
needs to go up one
object incompatible pointer
type. This is supposed to
be wait expected pi object but is pi
dict
object pi dict set item. Oh, because
this is
again the Python API is kind of
weird. Like it seems like it's not just
Python rubbing up against C and having
friction. It seems like just the API
wasn't like it could be better.
Okay. Now request for a member and not
instruct or
union. Um it should be there though
because
This log exists,
exists originally defined. Yeah, it's
getting the right
log. Oh, wait.
Redefinition in
binding
Oh, request for member and in something
not a structure or union.
I probably just screwed up the type
somewhere, right? Because it used to be
a
float. Oh, is it just straight up not
anywhere?
Yeah, this is just supposed to
be aggregate
n. Yeah.
Invalid type argument of
dot. And
now you just have to fiddle with
this cast.
Unknown type
log and
unknown type name
log mbfinding.h But I already included
pong which exports this
Yeah, this should definitely be
available.
It's not because of the type depth,
right? No, that doesn't make any
sense because I have
Good. Is there like some name conflict
or
something? But then it wouldn't be
um it wouldn't
be Yeah, it wouldn't be here.
This is going to be something really
dumb, isn't
here. Pong's included at the
top. Is this like some bizarro caching
thing?
Doesn't look like
it. Unknown type
What happens if I do
this redefinition of str
unknown. I figured it would be the log
being weird.
patient rock because I'm probably just
being that Stupid.
It still
happens.
Um, this is
weird. This is really weird.
includes pong which has the log
death and like if I try to do
str log
Okay. So now it shuts up at
least. Do we think that like Python or
NumPy have a log in
It's not going to compile for other
reasons,
right? No, we get the same
error. We get the exact same
error. Not a name conflict.
I'm staring at this thing and Pong gets
included before the end binding.
What are you
defining? M to um because it needs it's
just an
alias. Otherwise, you would have to name
all of your environment strcts.
M. I have this
like I don't know why the hell it can't
find this truck. This is driving me
nuts. Log is defined in pong.h And it
gets used here.
there. If I put it
here, still not
there. If I put it here, still not
there.
So if I put it in this
file now, I no longer get the error at
the
top. It's literally a matter of what
file I I put it
in. That's not how C works. Like what
the
Is there a way I can get it to output
the pre-process code? Uh, wait, that's
going to be gigantic. Are you just
compiling Pong and finding not having
guards and being included in Pong and
Breakout? They're being built as
separate extensions. So, that would be
really [ __ ]
But I will go look at
Oh, I'm dumb. Oh, I'm just really dumb.
Okay, that wasn't it. No, you got you
gave me the answer, but that wasn't
it. So,
um yeah, this is it's fine. It's not the
prog. It's
I was misreading the error message. I
didn't see that it's in breakout. I
thought that it was in
palm. Okay, it's fine.
Yeah, 31 should not happen. So, there's
a
this. It's funny. It does
actually. What in the
hell? All right, let's figure out what
the heck that is.
Is it because you populate your
dictionary before
averaging? Well, I populate it and then
I average
here. Yes. Yes, it
is. Though I don't know why that makes
it able to go negative.
Spencer. This is very, very close to
just being awesome. Awesome. Solid
intro. Oh, it can go negative because
the score function goes negative. Duh.
So the only thing is that uh n should
not be
this. We need n to be
correct. Go to
n. We just assign n like
this. We don't want to average our
averaging variable.
go. Now it's just because the games are
kind of long.
Cool. This works. This works.
It's supposed to get 20 score though.
Maybe that was just a little
unlucky. Let's run it
again. So,
um I I want to make sure that this
actually works. But let me show off what
what we've just done
here.
Okay, here's your binding function.
You write your init, you write your
log. Pretty much you just need to map
the
keys. Yeah. Okay. Perfect. So this does
work.
So this is your whole binding and
actually the logging gets to be even
better. So the logging now can use a
strruct again. You can use a strruct for
the log. You don't have any of those
additional
functions. You just write to the log as
normal. So this is even better than
before. You just have to write that
extra log
function which in exchange you no longer
have to define all the log keys.
So 30 line file. This is your entire
binding. We are very happy.
breakout. So you get your log, you get
rid of these keys that you had to
define. You no longer have this. You
just have log log.
And then end of episode lengths
for there you go. That's it.
almost works. We just need to define the
log thing obviously.
We could technically have a default
implementation as well. I don't know if
that's worth
doing. We could technically leave a
default implementation in if we wanted
to. So like this could be the default
implementation, right?
Okay.
Perfect. Now, neural MMO I kind of
messed up a whole bunch.
log. Yeah. So, we have to actually go
get this thing back now.
I don't know. I personally I think I'd
rather have this thing in here than all
this
mess. You still need was episode return,
episode
length,
not
mandatory, but um I would like all our
MS to have these because like when you
go to actually compare experiments in
your dashboard, it's really convenient
to have them under the same key. In
fact, you know, the most useful thing
would be is if we had episode return be
the return, which is the sum of the
score. Episode length is length just the
trajectory length but then score instead
of having score just equal episode
return most of the time or whatever.
Ideally we have score be normalized zero
to one something like that so that we
can actually put a whole bunch of M's on
one graph and we can get like an average
score across M's. That would be the
best.
Then we could return like one number for
evals.
also still multi m training media with
one
policy. Uh so that's a little harder
because you have varying observation
spaces. You would actually it's not
realistic to have all the M's have one
observation space. So you would probably
need some sort of like weird tokenizer
thing. That's the tough
part with that.
use but never defined. All right, now we
just have to define our
be. Right now we have this. All we got
to do is we add our log in
here. We just go get our log
right? You don't need to do N. It's done
for you. You can do it. It won't hurt
anything, but you don't need
to. And uh this is so easy even even
Grock can fill it in. Or not even Grock,
Super Maven can even fill this in.
That's it. That's your whole end
binding. So, 44
lines and it's really just a name
mapping. Okay.
member.
Oh, [ __ ] You did it in the wrong
This is
solid. Okay. And squared just because
squared should be super quick.
zero. Oh, no wait. It does do something.
It sets the end size.
doesn't have an init function
though. And then
log is going to be return length and
score probably or does it not have any
logging? I think square doesn't actually
have logging.
does. Why did it just give me an int
there?
No idea. Must have been auto
complete cuz that would screw you over
pretty
go. That's how it was before, right?
Yeah. Exactly how it was
before. All right. So now this goes
unpack does this
default and all this stuff can go.
Then the only thing is I need to change
some names.
Beautiful. This one has bad hypers on
it, but it should still
What did I miss?
Seed. Seed.
runs. Great. So, we now have uh all this
all set
up. Easy as that.
So that actually should take a lot more
than like two or three thousand lines
out of the codebase. Now with the
logging changes, that's going to take
like four or 5,000 lines out of the
codebase. That's great.
um you would save very little by doing
that.
You can even name them whatever you want
like this as well. They don't have the
same name. You can have like you can
name these differently if you want.
You could probably even put like slash
and stuff in if you want to have like
extended paths for logging. You can
probably just do
that. This is nice. I'm
happy. And at the very least, you know,
we really won't have to change anything
now. Like with the main M now that it
works like
this, pretty pretty solid.
I'll like I'll at least consider the
macro thing for a
second, but it seems like it's probably
pretty stupid, right?
Like what you would do like some unpack
all with all the
keys. That's kind of sketchy magic
though, right?
because then you would like you'd
basically be doing a string replacement
on this where you're like assigning each
me. I kind of like the way I have it now
where provided you're not counting like
this alias, there aren't any macros at
all in here.
This is this is the one I think this is
still really easy. This code is so brain
dead it'll like autocomplete itself for
you, right?
And if you actually go look at this,
like the source of this doesn't have any
stupid ridiculous magic
either. So I think that we
uh you know we allow you to have to have
a line per one line per uh variable and
in exchange it stays very very
simple. This is the entire dict
assignment thing. It's just, you know,
convenience. And then the entire um
where is it?
in there? It is. There's the entire
unpack. I think we are happy with
this. Yeah, this is good.
I will let Bet work on the rest of
these.
Did they really lie in the tweet
announcement for this? Are you kidding
me?
curriculum it is fair to say that it
like without the task
curriculum but it's not without human I
mean it depends if you consider Consider
tasks as human data.
know. It sucks cuz it's like this guy
put out a whole bunch of work and I
really wanted to like the work, but when
you dig into it, it just it's all fake.
It's like all [ __ ] Like crafter was
originally put together as like this
multitask cool environment that's like
fast and useful. It's unusably slow.
Done more damage to the field than it's
like done help just because of people
training on slow ass environments.
Ridiculous. Yes.
matter. It's
4:30. I've got maybe a good hour to
start on some training improvements.
It seems like we should be able to get
some like some PF out of
compile and
AM. Let me go look at the Lenar
Cudigraph thing again.
How been out of the loop for a bit? What
are you all doing currently? Well, we've
just cleaned up our binding system a
whole bunch. This is now all it takes to
bind neural MMO 3 to Puffer Live. No
Syon. Little bit higher PF transparent
debugging. It's very
nice. So, this is going to cut like
4,000 lines of boiler plate out of the
repository.
We got the 5090 up and running and now
I'm probably going to look at a little
bit of port compile stuff and see if I
can get some perf
replay you have to like trace it
essentially.
Did they do LSTM or
not? I don't think they even did LSTMs
with this, did
they? No, they
didn't. Okay, so that's a big
limitation.
You know, it's
like this probably does actually make a
decent
difference. They're using a tiny tiny
batch size though,
right? But
still, well, they get
6.8% 6.8x 8x speed
function. I probably can get this to
work. What did they do? They like they
made their own weird way to do this.
Yeah, they did like some weird rapper
thing for
Okay, this seems reasonable. So, we just
have to fix uh we have to fix compile
mode and then we will start on this a
little bit and then we will continue
this probably
run? Oh, maybe this is a torch version
thing, right? Because this does
compile. Yeah, this has an RN on it.
Okay. Yeah. So then the reason this
wasn't working in the other on the other
machine, it must just be a torch version
thing. So I don't even have to fix
compile. Compile just
works. And then uh pseudographs might be
the tough one.
can you explain what you did to get rid
of the boiler plate so
simply? So, we have this file. It's 500
line file, but this is all that's needed
for all environments.
And you can add as many as you want
without changing this. And there's some
redundancy. This can probably go down to
350 lines if I clean some stuff up. Um,
so what this file does, this just uses
the Python C
API. And it essentially does what the
Syon file does, but it just does it in C
with the Python API. So like instantiate
all your M's, right? Using a slice of
the observations, it does that. Step all
your M's running the loop in C. It does
that.
And then the other file that you saw was
just it leads you placeholders for where
you need to do your MS specific
initialization like passing arguments to
C and then your MS specific logging
passing the logs back out as a
dictionary. So this file is in dev. You
can see a lot of it is just this error
checking and then the actual logic of it
is stuff like this. you know,
vectorized reset, vectorzed step, so on
and so forth. And then the logging is
what I was working on
here. So, Python C API is kind of gross,
but I made it as simple as I could. And
it can probably get even a little bit
shorter than this.
is Syon dead for Puffer's use. I mean,
if you want to use it, you still can,
but I think this is better.
So like the 40 lines that we wrote for
neural MMO replaces 300 lines.
Um, I'm trying to think what's the
easiest way to integrate photographs
with this thing.
This one actually would be a decent test
because it's 42% in forward pass.
replay you
play. The problem is the OBS is not like
the same buffer, right?
So, I kind of have to restructure a few
things.
And then you actually need to use like
the
exact Scott
OBS. And these things all have to be
CUDA tensors, don't they?
This is kind of stupid the way this is,
isn't it?
Let's do it for now so we can at least
see if it's worth it.
All right. So, here we
do we'll just do this, right?
Yeah, I have no idea if this works.
We'll have to
Actually, what we can just do is we can
keep this as
is. It probably only gets used there,
right?
Yeah. So, I can just make this
observation space
it. So this is now literally
just super
easy. Uh, bath agents equals OB shape
zero. This
is agent.
cudigraph that has been overwritten by a
subsequent
clone the tensor before each model
invocation.
run. That doesn't make any sense. You're
accessing something that you're going to
overwrite in the future.
I mean, I can like here. Let's just like
really
see what we can do
here. Let's see if I can at least get it
to work and then we'll think about
making it fast.
or was it saying that you're not allowed
to write back to the
same the same variable? Is that it?
it? Oh, probably steak gets overwritten,
right?
Cannot
call current
seed the
weird. It doesn't even get to the
It doesn't even get
Cool blast status not
initialized. The heck?
I think I'm really going to need to
like fix this
thing, you know?
random the torch? Like the torch
internals kind of suck.
Are you supposed to be able to use this
without torch
compile? Yeah. So you are supposed to
use it with compile I
This has not been changed, right? Like
you can't just enable
this and maybe I was not
um given the full story here.
I'm probably going to have to go like
test this stuff in isolation if I really
want this to get working. So, this is
probably going to be a tomorrow
problem. We got really good progress on
the binding stuff
today. Maybe I'll start it later tonight
even. Um, yeah, I think that
like the CUDA craft stuff is quite quite
complicated.
I believe that this is like a possible
big perf improvement
though. So, we will try
that. Yeah, it'll it'll be worth
spending some time.
It's hard for me to say because
like you can do kind of anything with
really shitty code and make it faster or
really poorly optimized code I should
say. Clean R is awesome. It's just slow.
Um so yeah, it's
probably probably still worth doing.
Let me just at least start writing a
little little tiny test for this,
right? Because it shouldn't be that that
hard.
this. So, some weird [ __ ] happening with
compile. Ignore this.
Now it
works. Okay.
Oh, I
see. So, you got to do this, right?
difference. Is a very large
difference. And this should be like
decent batch as well, right?
No, it's not very decent batch size. Why
the hell is the batch that small?
course I should redo that. That's like
obnoxious.
If I can't figure out my own API, what
the [ __ ] am I doing?
hell? Yeah, this is actually just me
getting
interesting. That's very
interesting. It's still almost 3x. What
if I do like neural MMO?
Oh, you know what this is? You didn't do
No, Brad.
Ah, now the advantage goes
away with the bigger
model. It
seems if you do like one
Okay. So the
uh advantage has gone away
without without no
grad. I mean with uh with with no grad
the advantage is mostly gone
away unless you do
do. So you get uh you only really get
this performance boost if you have
stupid stupid dimensions.
You don't really get much even with the
smallest network once you have a
reasonable batch
size. I mean I guess like sometimes you
end up with stuff like this,
right? So that's still like something.
compile? Is there a way to get it to
work with
compile? Let's see if there was
Okay, so this just says use new torch or
whatever.
How the hell is this possible that it's
just like
garbage? The only really does anything.
It's photographs.
I'm not doing something incredibly
stupid here,
this. I think it doesn't compile
anything but the forward function by
default.
Nope. That looks way
slower. Yep. Way slower.
Unless it's this. Hang on. Maybe I
screwed this
up. Possibly counts these as different
ops.
[ __ ] compile,
man. Ridiculous.
ridiculous due to frequent
recompiles. Well, why is it recompiling
then? Is it just
trash?
Because like no combination of settings
does
So you actually were getting compile
speed ups on impulse wars Four.
I'm surprised you got it to work. For
me, torch compile has never done
anything.
model. Oh, lovely. Broke my
driver. Good job, Torch.
anything. Let me go update the model
before I forget to and I'm
sad. So, as far as I can tell, compile
doesn't do
anything. Like, I've tried this on a
different networks and it just sucks.
as far as I have seen.
All
right, I posted that on the Discord, so
you can try that. Um, I'm going to go
get some exercise and get food. I'll see
if I can be back after. But, uh, yeah,
compile doesn't freaking work.
Cudigraphs. Uh, it seems like it's not
really going to even do anything for us
is the thing because like I guess for
very small batches I it could be nice.
Like it could let us do a few things.
It's really a pain in the ass to
implement though.
And yeah, I think
1024 copies of the of an N with our
smallest possible network uh is where it
has to be for that to make any
sense. If I go to
2048, it's already less than a 10%
difference. Oh, actually the compiled
SPS goes up then.
That's
funny. Yay. The compile SPS goes
up. Ridiculous, man. It's ridiculous.
Now I've got to actually go check it.
Stupid
I mean, it does actually do something on
the stupid pong
network, right?
Barely. And you can't use both of them
together for some reason.
Is this a version issue that I can't do
this
This is a pretty new version of torch as
well. It's not like super
old. But I got to do this later. I
really need to go get some exercise. So,
we will call it there for the day.
Um, thanks for tuning in
folks. If you're interested in following
my stuff, puffer.ai start the GitHub to
help us out really helps. Join the
Discord to get involved with dev and
follow me on X for more RL content. I'll